Korona burg renaissance-fair took place  in nearby corona california now that's a  big deal yeah when something like that  happens people rely on this show to  respond a lot of colorful costumes a lot  of fun stuff they recreate a typical  German market fare from the 1600s so we  thought we got to cover this so we sent  around Andy Richter to the fair with a  camera crew did you enjoy yourself Andy  I really did here's my report Oh didn't  go to any Renaissance Faire no it's just  it's not really my thing but my my  nephew Tyler he loves that kind of stuff  so I sent him to the Renaissance Faire  with our camera crew and here's what he  found out  hey uncle Andy I don't know who told you  I was in the Renaissance Fairs but not  and it sounds lame so I put a GoPro on  my dog and told your camera crew just  let him loose in the Faire he can do it  [Music]  boarding from a bar two blocks from my  house this is Andy Richter back to you  Conan  good God  you